have you watched Rick and Morty no I
haven't many people have told me to
watch Rick and Morty although they said
it's very dark and well that doesn't
bother me so much I suppose although I'm
plenty dark perhaps without adding to it
so but I would like to watch it and I
probably will so I would love for you to
do come and do a talk in Montreal well
you never know that might happen I've
been talking to God sada both out a fair
bit you know he's coming to Toronto
November 11th so we can do the talk that
was shut down by Ryerson back in August
so I'm looking forward to that so what's
the best way to stop drinking alcohol
and start doing my best in my psychology
degree it's affecting my study but I can
do very well if I stop I'm 26
well Paul what I would say is I think
you should do the future authoring
program and you should really
concentrate there's a section in it that
helps you determine what your positive
view of your future would be but another
section that helps you determine what
would happen in your life if your
negative habits got out of control and
one of the things that can really help
you control your alcohol intake is to
really really think through what you're
giving up and where you could be in five
years if you don't get it under control
and proclivity to alcoholism can be a
really vicious thing you know lots of
people get dragged down into the mud by
alcohol excessive alcohol intake
especially if they're sensitive to the
opiate response that alcohol can produce
you could tell that if you when you
drink you know you get alert and let's
say more enthusiastic and energetic and
then you don't want to stop drinking
that's a that's definitely a bad sign
with regards to developing alcoholism so
I would say you need to figure out
something that's that's more important
to you than drinking and also think
through very hard the negative
consequences of continuing it you're at
about the age 26 where you should stop I
mean guys who are gonna stop generally
start slow down pretty pretty intensely
around that age
you know get also treating your
psychology studying as a full-time job
can also be helpful so you know get up
at 8:00 morning or 7:30 in the morning
and start hitting the books by 9:00 and
put in a 6 to 8 hour date and then even
if you do keep drinking at least you're
moving forward so that's what I can say
about that
are you a science-fiction fan you
reference timeline Starship Troopers in
a lecture and your ideas often remind me
of Harry Selden's plan from ASA mobs
foundation series
hey well when I was a kid which is quite
a long time ago now I lived in this town
called Fairview Alberta which was a town
of about 3,000 people way they held
North 350 miles northwest of Edmonton
and I had this neighbor across the
street across the alley actually and he
had a huge science-fiction library it
must have been I don't know five
thousand books there 1970s 1960s and
1970s classics like Heinlein then and
Asimov and he would let me go over there
and take like 20 books at a time then I
was reading about a book a day at that
point and I read science fiction like
mad probably till I was about 19 or so
and maybe a little younger than that and
then turned more to classic literature
when I got to college and and also
partly as a consequence of some lessons
that the local library had taught me
about what to read so I was a science
fiction fan
I haven't read science fiction for a
very long time although I was pretty
happy with it when I was a kid so